lobbyisten mit eigenen schreibtisch in
den ministerien und alle finden das ganz
normal ihre frau merkel vor unternehmern
sie haben aufmerksame verbände die
wissen manchmal noch bevor es überhaupt
nicht erreicht hat schon was da in den
stuben los ist und insofern machen sie
sich keine sorgen dass sie nicht
ausreichend beteiligt sind das passiert
schon von alleine
lobbyismus passiert von der leyen lustig
beziehungsweise gar nicht natürlich
dürfen unternehmen politiker in ihrem
sinne informieren das gehört zur
politischen willensbildung problemchen
wir haben auch nach vier jahren großer
koalition immer noch kein lobbyregister
das haben andere zivilisierte länder ein
lobbyregister wo drinsteht wer wen warum
trifft transparenz wäre doch wohl das
mindeste
oder haben wir aber nicht aber nicht in
berlin sowieso nicht aber deutsche
politiker versuchen gerade vor allem die
von union strengere
transparenzvorschriften in brüssel bei
der eu zu verhindern so und wenn sie
sich jetzt fragen wie wirkt sich denn
dieser böse lobbyismus aus ich gebe ihm
ein ganz aktuelles beispiel zucker can
sinne zucker dieses weiße zeug ohne dass
alles scheiße schmeckt ja
am montag am montag ist die sogenannte
zuckerquote in der europäischen union
gefallen
dadurch wird sogar noch billiger und man
wird noch mehr davon in unsere
fertiggerichte kippen
leider haben wir dank lobbyarbeit keine
lebensmittel ampel wir uns auf der
verpackung klar anzeigt wie viel zucker
im futter schlummert und im übrigen habe
ich die große sorge dass die
ampelkennzeichnung letztendlich zu einer
fehl- und mangelernährung der
bevölkerung führen würde
denn roth wird immer als warnung
verstanden ja eine warnung ist so noch
mal fürs protokoll jeder darf natürlich
essen was er will
keiner möchte ein nanny staat aber als
mündiger verbraucher muss sich doch
zumindest vernünftig informiert werden
tatsächlich gibt es dutzende von
zuckerarten die dank lobbyarbeit auf der
packung nicht zucker genannt werden
müssen
ihr auf einem live joghurt steht dann
zum beispiel zucker und anderer zirkus
und zeigt dass nicht sogar heiß aber
zucker ist glukose fruktose zero agaven
dicksaft stevia extrakt bauschaum
sägemehl und unten vorsicht kann spuren
von milch enthalten
mein gott
lobbyarbeit lobbyarbeit in dem fall geht
das ganze elend übrigens zurück auf eine
gekaufte zucker studie aus den usa schon
in den sechzigern die behauptet oder
behauptete schuld am übergewicht ist
überhaupt nicht zucker sondern
ausschließlich fed
deswegen gibt es heute so viele fettarme
produkte mit ganz viel zucker drin
wegen dieser studie wirklich die folgen
die folge übergewicht herz kreislauf
erkrankungen diabetes und so weiter klar
entlastet natürlich das rentensystem die
wirtschaftliche vereinigung zucker ev
sieht das thema naturgemäß ganz anders
und informiert uns im netz mit solchen
film das ist peter er treibt gerne sport
je mehr sich peter anstrengend desto
schneller muss sein körper energie an
die muskeln liefern und desto wichtiger
ist die zucker verbrennung speziell nach
dem sport sollte peter ein sportgetränk
mit 40 bis 80 gramm zucker pro liter
trinken
genau ein gesundes sportgetränk wie
fanta oder red bull der peter hier das
wäre die fortsetzung das ist bitter
früher hatte gerne sport gemacht aber
jetzt hatte darauf keine lust mehr
er trinkt lieber den ganzen tag
sportgetränke
das ist peter eine woche später sport
guckt er nur noch im fernsehen und seine
frau hat ihn verlassen weil er streng
riecht noch eine woche später steht
peter merz verfettung aber er hatte ein
erfülltes leben und es war nicht der
zucker ehrlich jetzt schöne grüße eure
zuckerindustrie
[Applaus]